foreign
[Music]
can't talk in a hurry and don't let my
dad catch you out here again what come
on he doesn't like my limbs
anyway June Bloom is coming and you just
got to be my date cause check it out I'm
all grown up
and I smell good
my queen
sorry buddy elements don't mix
flame gotta go come on go to the
festival with me you'll never leave this
part of town that's because everything I
need is right here
[Music]
[Applause]
plus the city isn't made with fire
people in mind sorry but it had taken
Act of God to get me across that bridge
an act of God or an act of Claude
[Music]
how would you do that
it's the minerals check this out
awesome
[Music]
watch this
[Applause]
[Music]
oh sorry
you're so hot
excuse me
no I mean like you're smoking no I
didn't mean it like that are you done
yet yes please I'm waiting to talk to
your boss so make like a stream and flow
somewhere else actually Gail won't be in
today she's a huge airball fan and the
windbreakers are finally in the playoffs
too dude okay well I just came by
because I left my passes for the game
here last night
like plural
[Applause]
thank you
hey fern
how you doing living the dream
citations I just gave you from firetown
I was about to send them to Mrs cumulus
then get sprayed for fungus Drive wait
tell them what you told me
about no that's personal it really got
to me he might feel it too her dad will
be yep so no
point didn't hurt stop it he might even
be here
what are you doing but the main thing is
if her father can't retire it will be
all Embers
looks like I'm going home early today
you really food inspector as far as you
know yeah
then inspect this
dad
yep oh it's good to me no no no inspect
with your mouth oh
you see he likes it
our blue flame hold all our traditions
and give us strength to burn right
[Music]
do I burn a Sprite
foreign
someday it'll all be yours
[Music]
meet the residents of element City
Air usually has their head in the clouds
oh my new jacket Earth can be a little
seedy nothing weird going on here just a
little pruning water is always getting
into something
[Music]
and fire as ordered we run a little hot
this shop is dream of our family someday
it'll be yours but we all live by one
simple rule
[Music]
[Applause]
pipe squished me all out of shape
that's better oh
so you've never left firetown sorry
buddy elements don't mix
plus my dad would boil you alive why
doesn't anyone get to tell you what you
can do in your life come on
why do they even have these yes who
knows
watch this
remember Amber I see a change in you
what hair guy you live here it's my
mom's place we got two kids that are
swimming around here somewhere
I've been trying to fill my father's
shoes I never once asked what I wanted
to do
right this Dad those are too hot I love
hot food
[Music]
[Applause]
you see he likes it
a world of element City includes air
water Earth and fire elements cannot
miss and when they clash it's actually
pretty funny
I'm sorry when you make a film about
elements you are just setting yourself
up for the puns
winner winner charcoal dinner
maybe we play The Crying Game let me
guess you try to cry we try not to cry
oh honey you won't believe what your
baby niece did today she she smiles
oh
Catherine O'Hara how can she make crying
sounds so funny
it was really fun to record
sorry it does something really special
like how did you guys actually do this
to be able to see all the different
characters pop out at you and really
come to life oh my goodness after seeing
my character we are total twins
like looking in a mirror two two
I think putting your heart into the
story is a big ingredient to what makes
the Pixar film work I've just never been
punched before faced with beauty before
I think the only way to get close to
appreciating it is to see it on a big
screen it is fun it is funny it's just
so full of life this will just hit you
right in the feels that's what Pixar
does best
[Applause]
[Music]
seriously
[Applause]
you're so hot excuse me no I mean like
you're smoking you know I didn't mean it
like that are you done yet yes please
hello
babe Amber oh I don't want to pick you
out okay I love hot food
that pipe squished me all out of shape
that's better
oh
watch this
thank you
no I'm reading the wrong line let's do
that again
[Music]
[Applause]